what's up guys I'm pretty excited today
I'm going to assemble all of the new
LEGO minifigures the Disney collection
let's go
you
Oh
watching I hope you enjoyed this video I
absolutely love what new many figures
are out it's pretty much something that
I look forward to more than anything
really I mean if you guys have a faint
Finny finger from this series I think
buzz is probably my favorite you guys
know that my buzz lightyear had a little
incident at Disney last year but this is
a new and improved buzz he's pretty cool
those are worse in the night and you
come around my upside down
cuz when you
I can't stop feeling
you
answer please please I'll be
you wanna play with me